human beings by default are hesitant to
change but every now and then something
shows up that so hyped up that we might
actually believe that it's okay to
change I am route from simply learn and
today we're going to talk about Phi
industries that blockchain will disrupt
let's start with banking suppose you are
in San Francisco and you want to send
money to your friend now for this
transfer to take place you need the help
of a central authority in this case it's
the bank now say you sending them $100
now out of this hundred dollars ten
dollars goes this transaction field to
the bank the rest goes to your friend
which is $90
now this transaction fee at times can be
expensive the process of transferring
money can also be time-consuming the act
of sending money overseas is also a lot
more complicated due to the exchange
rates and other hidden fees
now blockchain is disrupting the system
by providing a peer-to-peer payment
system but this provides high security
and doesn't cost as much this system
eliminates need of a central authority
no blockchain provides fast cheap and
bodiless payments across the world you
can perform transfers to any part of the
world
no crypto currencies like Bitcoin
eliminates the need for a third party in
this case a bank to make transactions
now blockchain records all the
transactions in a decentralized ledger
this ledger is accessible by any of the
Bitcoin users for example let's talk
about the cryptocurrency application
caller bruh this provides peer-to-peer
money transfers now this application
allows users to store transfer and
receive digital money which can be
stored in their mobile phones or PCs the
recipient can withdraw this cash via an
Abra teller the most important thing
here is that users don't need to have a
bank account to use this service next up
we have cyber security now imagine
you're in office one day and you find
out that your date has been modified the
previous evening someone went through
your data and altered it now cyber
attacks are a huge cause of concern
among the public it can have huge
repercussions to a person's life so it's
essential that we find an effective
solution against people going through a
data unauthorized and tampering it
that's where blockchain comes in
blockchain with its decentralized system
makes it suitable for environments where
there's a lot of security required all
the information that's stored inside the
Bitcoin networks are verified and
encrypted using a cryptographic
algorithm now this ensures that there's
no single point of entrance
for a wide-scale attack now with
blockchain it's also easy to identify
malicious attacks due to the
peer-to-peer connections where data
cannot be altered or tampered by
ensuring that there's no central
authority blockchain provides a
transparent and secure way of recording
transactions this is at the same time
ensuring that none of your private
information is disclosed to anyone for
example let me tell you about a company
called guard time that secures data
using blockchain technology now guard
time uses a completely unorthodox method
as opposed to a centralized system this
company uses blockchain technology it
distributes the data among the nodes of
its users now let's talk about supply
chain management say you ordered for
some food from online you get the
delivery for the food you get the food
delivered to you and you find out that
the food has surprisingly low quality
now with blockchain technology you can
trace the supply chain back to its
beginning to find out where things went
wrong for example you can find out where
the farm is where the product is grown
how the production was whether something
went wrong with the distributor whether
something went wrong with its retailer
but something went wrong at your head
now in supply chain management
blockchain provides permanent
transparency and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain partners that means you can
validate each and every step of the
supply chain all the blockchain entries
are permanent and transparent this makes
it easier for the customer to view the
transaction history of the product pages
purchased in a blockchain transactions
are recorded in a decentralized
distributed ledger each transaction is
recorded into a block and anyone can
verify the authenticity or status of a
product being delivered now it can also
be used for seafood verification here we
can track the seafood from ocean to the
market now take the example of the
Pacific tuna project now you have three
blocks here each one containing fishing
details export and import details and
purchasing details the blockchain supply
chain management provides a step-by-step
verification to track the tuna fish in
the process this prevents illegal
fishing next up we have health care say
you're in a hospital and you're asking
for reports for our medical tests you
did yesterday the receptionist tells you
to wait and even after four hours you
still don't get your report apart from
those annoying delay have you realized
that any person who has access to the
system
can corrupt the data apart from this
annoying delay have you realized that
any person who has access to the system
can corrupt the data since information
is stored in the physical memory of the
system blockchain eliminates a central
authority and ensures that you have
rapid access to data here
each block is connected to another block
and the data is distributed across the
nodes this makes it difficult for a
hacker to corrupt the data another major
problem in healthcare is counterfeit
medication the main issue is that
conflict masons are difficult to
distinguish from real medicines the
solution comes in the form of blockchain
with the help of supply chain management
here the medicines provenance can be
traced
for example United Healthcare has
improved its privacy security and
interoperability of medical records
using blockchain now time for some
honorable mentions the insurance
industry with block chains decentralized
system insurance companies can easily
identify false claims and prevent
forgeries transportation utilizing
blockchain enables traceability in the
transportation industry where the
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
now let me tell you about cloud storage
with an example storage is a
decentralized cloud storage by
eliminating servers and utilizing
blockchain it can securely store its
data in the cloud with high speed and
low cost users can earn money by sharing
their extra hard drive space on the
storage network real estate deploying
blockchain technology in real estate
increases the speed of the conveyance
process and eliminates the necessity for
money exchanges let's talk about the
government in a traditional voting
process electoral fraud is a legal
activity that takes place almost always
now most citizens who want to vote must
wait in a queue and cast their vote to a
local authority this can be very
time-consuming process why not bring
this process online online voting
systems fail due to the lack of security
blockchain can be used to solve these
issues it can be used for counting votes
and verifying borders using blockchain
voters can submit their watch without
revealing their identity in public
officials can count the words with
absolute accuracy knowing that each ID
has only one word associated with fake
Watts cannot be created as data
tampering is closed impossible with
blockchain once your water is added to
the ledger the information can never be
reached now let me tell you an example
of me would know me vote is a token
based blockchain platform which is very
similar to a digital ballot box now with
me what people are able to vote through
a smartphone so voters cast the vote
after the verification the word gets
recorded in the blockchain the water
identities are secured and the results
are not modified but blockchain is also
useful in some other things for digital
asset registries with blockchain fast
and secure registration of any asset is
possible it can be used to the node tree
utilizing blockchain technology with the
node
can be a really fast way to prove our
documents authenticity with tax
deploying blockchain can result in
quicker tax payments lower rates of tax
evasion and lesser efforts in tax
auditing blockchain can increase
security and transparency in
governmental systems by 2020
Dubai hopes to become a hundred percent
blocks in government by making all of
its government services available on the
blockchain technology and with that
we're at the end of another video I hope
you guys found this video helpful and
informative thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from simply learn hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos
turner up and get certified click here